when it comes to symbols of the past
there are still a lot of people who
ascribe extra natural powers to symbols
sign of the cross number 13. lux symbols
bad luck symbols at what point though do
benign symbols become malignant
you're one of the sharpest students i've
ever had
raw answer i could only take you so far
peter i knew this was going to be
life-threatening i would have just gone
to the library
professor
i was expecting peter he asked me to let
you know about the urgent situation
hello you will solve the great mystery
peter will point the way
that's peter's ring
[Applause]
i teach symbology i expect you'll find
the sun the lantern the key the hand of
the mysteries
could this person say what he wants he
wants me to locate an ancient portal
buried within the capitol
and unlock it how's your latin not as
good as my hair babe
did you happen to put that key back you
mean this no no one told me to put it
back
you didn't think it was gonna be that
easy did you
there's a purpose to everything he's
done world wants to be deceived
so let it be deceived
[Music]
you